كمبيوتر
نجل الرئيس الامريكي كلمه سر واحده لفتح
واسرار كثيره بداخله
على كثره الجبهات المعارك التي يفتحها على
نفسها وسنتطرق لها بعد قليل فتح اخرى
جديده
عام 2020 تويتر قيد الوصول الى مقالات حول
كمبيوتر
السياسيه في التعاملات التجاريه ماسك
التحود على تويتر
من البريد الالكتروني للمنصه حول القرار
ساظهر الوثائق هكذا تحدث ماسك كلمته
مدعومه باستطلاعات للراي سته وستون في
المئه من الامريكيين يعتبرون ان الكمبيوتر
الخاص
يكون متورطا في تعاملات
ليس ماسكه واحده
الجمهوريون ايضا بداوا طبعا فتحه ملفاتهم
وايضا بدعم استطاعات الراي
62% من الامريكيين يدعمون التحقيق مع هنتر
بايدر وكلمه مؤثر الجمهوريه هناك ما ذكرنا
هي كمبيوتر
هانتربوينتر لاشهر في ورشه لصيانه
الحواسيب لناخذكم في هذه الرحله شركه
الغاز الاوكرانيه بوريسيما احدى كلمات
السر داخل هذا الكمبيوتر عامله هنتر عضوا
بمجلس ادارتها عام 2014 وهذه امور عاديه
ما غير العاديه هو راتبه ثلاثه وثمنون الف
دولار شهريا هل يستحقوا وهنتربوينت المبلغ
لا اجابه قاطعه لكن المعطيات هي انها
خبراته ضعيفه وتحديدا في قطاع الغاز
راتبه هانتر لطالما اثار التساؤلات وعندما
تخرج حصل على وظيفه براتب عالم في شركه
امبي ان اي بمسخه راس والده شركه ادعمها
بيضا في مجلس الشيوخ
لنعود الان الى بورسما وقتها كان بيضا
نائبا للرئيس فهل الامر صله
بعد تركي بيضه لمنصبه من 83 الفن الى
41.000$
للشركه التي اسسها اصلا وزير البيئه
الاوكرانيه السابقه
كانت تمنح تراخيص الاستكشاف التي استفادت
منها بوريسما وهنا يظهر ايضا نائب الرئيس
حينها بايدا كان مكلفا بمحاربه الفساد في
اوكرانيا
ديسمبر 2015 سافر الى كياب وضع خطا على
الحكومه الاوكرانيه لا نريد هذا المدعي
العام وبالفعل اجبر شوكين على ترك منصبه
في 2016 بعدين لم ينكر دوره في ذلك لكن بح
جه
انفنتي
[موسيقى]
ساخنه تبدا في يناير المقبل مع توعد عدد
من اعضاء الحزب الجمهوريه الرئيس جودا عبر
فتحي ملفات بتحقيقات عديده تخص التعاملات
الماليه والتجاريه لنجله
ويعتقد الجمهوريون ان تعاملات التجاريه
الخارجيه
ربما عرضت البيت الابيض للخطر وبالتالي
فهي مصدر قلق للامن القومي
مهنه والده السياسيه الناجحه لاسراء نفسه
وانهم ضمه الى مجلس اداره شركه غاز طبيعي
اوكرانيه عام 2019 كما ساعدت شركه
استثماريه شارك هانتر في تاسيسها شركه
صينيه على شراء منجم كوبال في الكونغو من
شركه امريكيه عام 2016
وبينما يخدع حاليا لتحقيق في وزاره العدل
في شان انتهاكات ضريبيه محتمله تتعلق
بعمله في الخارج كذلك مساءا بانه اد بيان
كاذب اثناء شراء سلاح الا انه لم توجه له
اتهامات باي جرائم حتى الان لكنها تربايدن
يصر على ان تعاملاته الماليه والتجاريه في
الصين واوكرانيا كانت قانونيه على رغم
اعترافه بان حياته المهنيه استفادت على
الارجح من الروابط العائليه